Try Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
but I didn't see it.
I wish that a fighter's appreciate the
science of boxing more.
When GSP one of those fights he train
with Freddie Roach and it came back with
that Fucking Jab.
It made waves,
but a lot of people didn't copy that.
Arlovski did first it was like,
no,
let's just go boosh,
you know,
he's like,
holy Amanda Nunez boxing trainers.
Howard Davis,
his son.
Okay.
And American top team.
So she's,
I don't know why people don't
incorporate it that much.
More like that.
This is so much to learn.
You said there's three levels of
striking pretty much in the UFC.
You know,
we had a discussion last night when,
when,
uh,
the Jujitsu guy won.
Seventy came in,
you know,
he came in and he was a great Jujitsu
guy.
He wanted a,
what's his name?
The guy that triangle jail from the top.
Damien.
Damien Maia.
That guy came in.
He went to the first couple of matches
Jujitsu.
Then somebody told him he was a boxer.
He started getting lit up and it
happened.
He's fucking back to just grab your leg
and it's all funded.
Rhonda.
Hundred percent.
Rhonda just said,
okay,
I'm gonna.
Take a year off.
I'm going to go to the Olympic wrestling
a facility wherever.
Just focus on wrestling.
Still work on your striking.
Go with Duane Ludwig.
That would be awesome.
Or,
or Rafael Cordeiro.
Mix it up.
You know what I mean?
You've got to change shit up now
obviously.
Um,
but wrestling should be the focus.
When you see a Rhonda Rousey Promo,
you shouldn't see her getting mets.
You should see her shooting,
getting the clench.
Double leg,
take down singles.
It should be wrestling every day.
Twice a day for think about her camp,
her whole camp.
It's just a boxing gym.
Coaches a boxing coach,
so they want her to be this boxer.
People sold her as a next Mike Tyson.
So you have all that coming in and she
was murky and girls remember I was on
board.
I'm like,
damn her striking.
She's knocking bitches out.
Then you start to level.
It's like,
what's coming up?
She's knocking them out of that.
But.
But I,
I think the media in a lot of people are
like,
Dang she,
she's a knockout artists.
So you hear those in her going,
your knockout artist,
you can strike with anyone.
Right.
And her coach like,
look,
that was always the case.
You remember when Gerald fought in the
UFC,
it was always the case when Gerald is a.
was he a black male back then or brown
belt?
It was a brown belt.
Really Good Jujitsu guy though.
But his fucking striking coach had it.
I'm convinced that he was a Thai boxer.
He's like,
you're going to go out there and get a
kick.
And I remember Eddie and I would watch
him hit the bag and hit the meds and
stuff.
And I was like,
man,
there's some scary guys in the UFC.
And he got a real scary one.
And Josh Thompson,
Josh Thompson was like,
Yep,
none of that.
No,
no,
it wasn't.
It didn't go down like that and then got
happening.
No.
What ended up happening as Gerald's
Jujitsu's jokes treatment as we're
talking about his.
He was my first student,
my first before 10th planet.
I was teaching Jujitsu to a guy named
Gerald Street,
then he a blue belt at the time and I
brought them up,
shut him up.
He got really good at the twister,
really good at rubber guard,
rubber who first meet Hook,
rubber guard triangle and MMA history.
Uh,
in a gladiator challenge show.
He was kicking ass and then he fires
John Silva in England in London,
and it was a spectacular match.
A Joe showed that fight to,
uh,
Dana White.
Dana white game was shot game.
Josh Thompson,
he started,
he started working more a pie with this,
this Muay Thai coach,
and it was six months.
He was training six months with them,
right.
And he'd been doing any.
He wrestled in high school as well.
So He'd been grappling a total at that
point.
Joey reading into the mic.
I'm hearing some for sure.
Joe was just confused in my head.
But anyway,
so anyway,
so he was interested and it's an
interesting point.
I was just thinking about this.
It's the exact same thing.
It's when I'm,
when I'm striking like let's say I got,
I'm a striker,
Muy Thai,
came in and he'd been doing more type
for 10 years and he wanted to learn the
ground and he was doing mma.
He's already fighting.
MMA.
Comes up a lot.
I'm going to show them Jujitsu.
I'm going to be in his corner.
I'm not going to be telling him to take
his ass down and work up into Jitsu.
Well,
guard,
I'm like,
you just it.
It's been six months this relaxed,
but what I was getting involved,
what I want to see is that dude when
with his tie and it gives me another
fight to get his Jujitsu and again,
the longer we void that you did sue in
my eyes,
the patter we.
Whew.
We got away with another one.
Now we have another four or five months
to work on the Jujitsu way of looking at
it,
but there's a lot out.
There's a lot of strikers striking
coaches out there that will take some
grappler in,
teach them striking for six months and
then a corner him in an mma fight and
like instruct him to stand with this
motherfucker.
Pull the guy to the side state.
Do,
don't listen to this guy.
You're not standing.
Do you remember what he said?
You know how many times I had to say
that up like my guys,
like,
tell him,
listen to this motherfucker.
He's taking this motherfucker.
He came out in jail.
I remember what he said.
Do you remember what he said to him?
He's ready.
Yes.
In six months instead was Bangkok.
Greg,
he's going to go out there,
so this is what I look at it.
It was a.
It was a good thing.
It's a good thing because this is what
happened.
Is He Adam,
so believing that he was Bangkok ready
after six months of Moitai that when he
did the walkout in the UFC,
he came out with a,
a,
a bicep bracelets or whatever,
tigar dancing,
and during the time he was in the
octagon and did you know he went around
the Octagon and blessed?
Yes.
Doing that through Josh Thompson sitting
there and I talked to Josh Donaldson
since then.
Josh Thompson wrestled in high school
and he's a good striker.
He was fucking up people off his back.
He was triangling people.
We knew all about Josh Thompson.
Gerald was not.
He was not in the best frame of mind for
that fight.
You know what?
Because Josh Thompson was a fucking
killer back then.
He was a kid.
Well,
he was in his prime back then.
That was josh when he was.
He was one of the top,
like five or six guys in the division.
He got rid of the 155 pound division.
It was him and Eve Edwards and Eve
Edwards knocked him out.
I was like,
Eva,
where's became an uncrowned king?
So this would happen.
So luckily,
and this is according to Josh Thompson
told me,
Josh goes,
dude,
I was so worried about a standard time
stop that when we saw the fight,
my whole thing was how do we know the
whole.
The whole thing was for sure Josh
Tomlin's not going to want to go to the
ground with Gerald.
That's where all this good shit is.
He's fucking people up in Nma.
All his fights up until the USC was
fucking people up with the Jujitsu.
So how are we going to get the fight to
the ground?
We were thinking about pulling an
elaborate,
a unorthodox cardpool.
How are we going to do it?
That's what I was thinking like six
months.
I go,
I know he thinks he's Bangkok ready.
That's six months,
man,
you know,
so,
so.
So Josh takes him down and I was sitting
there thinking,
what the fuck thing?
He takes a general dental because he's
so worried about his tie and Gerald do
right away throws up a hellfire with his
guard.
He threw a lot of heat.
It was pretty bad ass to see.
But at the end of the day,
first he almost had him in an arm bar.
Josh pulls out and then there's like a
scramble on the ground.
Gerald ghost for a leg lock because he
finally pulls out of his garden.
Then general who was really good at like
locks and he went for a leg lock and
then Josh Thompson hit him like in the
back of the head of the killer.
That was one of those.
Yeah.
That was one of those going,
you know,
going to lead boxes.
Risky.
What started this all off?
Uh Oh.
You bolded those coaches.
Coaches get these fucking people
convinced that they're trying to kill
killer in one particular camp though
because in every campus,
especially if you have like a super star
camp and it come from my own personal
experience,
you have a superstar wrestling coach,
boxing coach,
Jujitsu coach,
you know,
you're spending your time with them.
They want to see you win with all their
shit.
Yes.
Even my coaches get tossed them off.
The W should be number fucking war.
It's nice when they win with some shit
of course,
like fucked up.
Like you showed me that shit that's
always good,
but it's all about the Goddamn dumpy.
That's number why you gotta have like a
head coach.
You got to have a head coach that's not
a striking coach.
Hundreds like a head coach,
Matt Hume as a head coach.
You know like when he works with Dj,
they do everything,
you know,
they work on submissions together,
spar together,
he worked,
they work on all these different
techniques and it's total technique and
tactics oriented conversations.
And how many stars are though in the
world?
Like five.
If one is honestly this like in my mind
it's like he,
if he's not number one,
it's him and for us a hobby,
but I count two that can do it all.
That really know the game in and out.
Can do a game plan from standing to
restroom to grapple.
Yeah.
I wouldn't mean.
I think those are the one guy might be
better for you.
One guy might be better for the other,
but those are the.
Those are the top dogs too because
there's such wizards on the ground are
wizards to and they.
They could physically do it too.
That's like a big part of it and plus
they know the transition.
Like sometimes if you go to a pure
Jujitsu guy,
you're like,
dude,
this isn't gonna work.
If I commit both hands this I'm gonna
get blast in the face.
Do you remember what George Grid Gel
like?
He was a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu
back when there was very few black
belts,
but then he became.
He wanted to stand and bang with
everybody and that was his thing.
He became this thing standing in banging
and that's.
That happens so often.
It's so crazy.
It's so rare that a guy comes back and
figures it out.
Like Damien Maia House.
Damien Maia tried it that way for
awhile.
Yup.
You got sucked into it and they figured
that's exactly the time.
Rhonda should they took it to what says
expression.
You go to the dance or took it to their
I don't know.
I know a lot of early.
I saw a lot of high level Jujitsu guys
come into the UFC that the hands a Mensa
mense yeah.
Like it's like a three striking and they
never evolved to that.
Now the fucking striking is evolving
quick a quick,
you know,
it used to be that the only guys that,
the only black belts that got to the UFC
were like the guys that were only
dedicated their lives to get to.
They just started learning and striking.
You can tell,
you can tell like holy shit,
they're just trying to fucking get some
kind of clench.
It's obvious,
but now with,
there's so many goddamn black belts in
Brazil now that it's not about,
it's all about,
you know,
here's,
here's 100 black belts in the camp.
We're only going to take the best
strikers.
Like the fierce ones.
You know,
the guy,
the days of pure Jujitsu guys coming out
and looking like this,
that there are long gone now.
You can't,
you can't get,
get through the minor leagues swiping
like that.
Your attitude is like,
I got this.